let me just go back to the original
point that i was talking about with like
putting on muscle because i found that
that picture and it popped up but this
one here is about
i'm going to say i was 29 30ish there
and this is about 41 or so now this is
pre-trt
okay right didn't didn't really change
much so i never really had a hard time
you know like putting on muscle
and like you know keeping it but i
always had that interest
in performance-enhancing drugs because i
if i'm being honest i probably had um
they called it bigorexia when i came
across it in muscle media magazines you
know with bill phillips and stuff like
that
and it's like you know you never feel
like you're big enough you know it's
like you know
you bench you know three three and a
half plates you squat three
you know three or four plates and you're
like you know you want to get to five or
six and you see those guys in a magazine
you just keep pushing and pushing
and you can never achieve the size that
comes with the strength so you kind of
like have this mental image in your mind
that you should be bigger but
there's but there's a cost associated
with that
isn't there like you know it doesn't
number on your on your
uh bones you know your joints your
ligaments your organs yeah your whole
body
really like the bodybuilding what you
see in the magazines that's just a
picture
and it doesn't represent the what's
going on internally
so that's why we like in the beginning
people started using steroids for
bodybuilding
because there was only bodybuilding
hormone replacement therapy didn't
really exist
unless it was like a real clinical
androgen deficiency
and then people didn't go to puberty and
that kind of stuff and most of the
steroids that were designed
were designed for other medical purposes
and
sarcopenia muscle wasting disease bone
mineralization issues and
masterone was even used to help mitigate
breast cancer
right in women so that's a steroid being
prescribed to women
now the bodybuilding world started
adapting that and then of course
developed phenomenal physiques with that
but a lot of people use
dosages that are way higher that are
medically prescribed
and um like for the trt guys we have a
little bit of an image
that steroids are going to give this
physique that we see in the magazine or
on instagram or on youtube
yeah which in reality is not the case um
because the pharmacology involved
to be a bodybuilder is far and far far
higher
than what we do for well-being
anti-aging right to have a little bit
stable serum concentrations of your
testosterone estrogen and
get more productivity out of it so
there's there's a big difference
and if you want to be a bodybuilder well
you're going to have to bump up the
dosages far beyond hormone replacement
yeah but if you you started out as a
natural bodybuilder when did you start
you know experimenting with peds when i
was 26 so i started bodybuilding when i
was 15.
and honestly i i did not respond so well
i'll be the first one to say it like my
pictures did not look as good
as yours i was trying to make career
like business came first
and i would put bodybuilding second so i
would do the meals
i would do the training but i was not
living like a full-time bodybuilder
where
everything revolves around training and
eating and maximizing that avenue
because
well up until social media there was no
real money in it
yeah well there's still not a lot of
money in it today unless you have a
large audience right
uh well you'll be surprised
like some guys are really banking on it
really even
yeah yeah through social media of course
because like if you're
just localized and you're a personal
trainer you're not really banking
but through social media with all the
discount codes and offering services
coaching consultations and
ebooks and there's a decent amount of
money to be made
okay but when i started and when you
started there was no social media to
promote
your uh avenue so i i never really
thought about taking steroids because
i was happy with how i looked i mean for
the business world i was already too big
right being natural and saying too big
and then
when that business thing kind of fell
apart due to the economic crisis
in 2008 2009 that's when i decided you
know what
bodybuilding is my passion i'm going to
see what the fuss is all about and i
started with a cycle
so but that was after 11 years of
drug-free bodybuilding
yeah and another like what did you do
for a cycle of that time to
like enter into the competing world um
250 tests per week
which was half of what was generally
recommended online
and they recommend 500 tests and the
annual kickstart i just made a video
about that
yeah we'll be online shortly um and it
didn't
really make much sense to me because you
saw a lot of these cycle logs on
the steroid forums and people would get
ton of side effects
within week five or six and so i figured
you know what i'm gonna start low
like the at that time hormone
replacement therapy was already present
so i just started with a little bit
higher than hormone replacement and i
had good results
and is that something that you run year
round or is it like you'll use it to try
to
you know build a physique compete you
know do a photo shoot and you kind of
taper it back to
like hrt levels like a like a
therapeutic dose to try to
keep you at a consistent level so at the
time i ran a cycle for 16 weeks because
plastic and cruising wasn't really
understood and and right coming down to
a lower dose
wasn't really popularized yet we were
talking about 10 years ago
because i'm 37 now and so i i did my
cycle i came off i did post
psychotherapy
is this and then i uh travel to no
that's that's a recent picture
oh that's recent so that's like yeah
yeah no nobody looks like this on their
first cycle
yeah i was trying to scroll through here
because there's one in here where you
just look like a huge
tank i mean like you know here you got
the shoulders like boulders right
yeah yeah here was still a pretty saucy
yeah
so there's somewhere on my instagram
there's an old picture yeah
yeah every year ago always big like like
always a big dude
what's your um height and weight
normally um right
um i'm 5'9 75 centimeters
okay and i i think the heaviest i got to
was like 255 pounds 115 kilos
wow that's a lot of muscle for
for that height yeah yeah and the weird
thing is like when you're that big you
don't see how big you are you still
think you're too small
no you're because you're actively you're
actively trying to chase that and then
you see a picture next to a normal
individual
yeah yeah like man
really because you're always comparing
yourself to other bodybuilders it's
yeah like that's where the big rexia and
a little bit of the curse comes into
play because you surround yourself in
that little
niche little circle of astronomically
huge dudes
yeah you always think you're the
smallest yeah yeah that's that's where
the abuse comes into play so
um right i took some time off i did
another post psychotherapy recently
um to result in non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease which came from the
lifestyle
and now that's how did you get that like
like talk about that because you went
off all peds everything changed your
diet completely like
i was following your updates when you
were doing that um
you lost a lot of weight and muscles you
know
not as much muscles you you'd think but
i mean a lot of it came back but i mean
you also started doing things like icing
your balls and
trying to like kick start your own um
testosterone production which
it looked like you're quite successful
like one of the questions a lot of
people ask me whenever i start leaning
into like trt conversations i don't
i'm by no means a research expert like i
lean on guys like you and jay campbell
and a few other people that i
look towards plus the literature that
i've read but i mean like uh
it seemed like it was pretty easy for
you to kick-start your own testosterone
production to
healthy levels right yeah yeah i mean
listen i didn't need it medically when i
was 26 my testosterone was around 650
nanograms per deciliter so that's middle
middle of the reference range and i
think i could have gotten it higher with
the information that i have nowadays
right i'm
i've learned a lot more since the age of
26. so
when i decided to come off after
blasting cruising and you know
you do a bodybuilder cycle you go back
to hormone replacement to clean out get
healthy
do a bodybuilder cycle again and i did
that for about eight years straight
now this lifestyle uh the high foods
right taking health supplements uh
never really giving your body a break
from steroids um
ultimately gave me non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease and i i think
that i have a genetic predisposition for
it because
what is that if you can define it for
the viewers so they know what that is
the non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
yeah yeah so that's
buildup of fat within the liver now
naturally there is fat present in the
liver
that's normal you have about three four
five percent fat in the liver i mean
it's an organ and most
most organs have a little bit of fat
that's totally healthy but
as fat builds up over time you develop a
disease called non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease you have alcoholic fatty liver
disease that's
induced by alcohol that later leads into
stealth doses and
fibrosis and so that's very difficult to
resolve
so when it's not alcoholic it's a it's a
result of diet lifestyle
did did did peds you know contribute to
the damage to your liver
yes it did yes but not in the direct
sense it's more that
because i didn't come off so i didn't
really come off off
not even hormone replacement okay um
because when you have super
physiological amounts of testosterone
that is higher than natural production
your stem cells in the liver are not
able to
restore the amount of hepatocytes which
are the liver cells
to have a healthy liver again so
some people go down to hormone
replacement therapy like true
hormone replacement therapy being 125
milligrams of testosterone per week
which i could have done right i could
have done to real hormone replacement
therapy and then resolve the issue
but i figured okay i'm not going to be a
bodybuilder i'm not going to eat so much
and i took these steroids for
bodybuilding so why not recover
and see if i can get my fertility my
testosterone levels
and all that stuff back because again
and then maybe prove to myself that i
need it medically which i don't
and because my testosterone came back
with all the effort that i put into it
so that was icing the testicles
and right as silly as it sounds it's you
put an ice pack in
wrapped in a tile 20 minutes around your
testicles three times per day
and it helps with fertility and
testosterone production it sounds
absolutely silly but it worked
yeah i've heard that with cold showers
and ice baths so i could see how that
would help
were there any other supplements that
helped to restart your own production
and get your testosterone levels back to
a healthy level like did you use
anything like tongue gut alley did you
supplement with zinc boron copper
yeah all that so i did not use uh tone
cut alley but i use ashwagandha root
extract
which uh also has some clinical evidence
that it raises testosterone
concentration so i took
in the beginning i took way more like
900 milligrams and then i kind of
tapered it down
because there's an effective dose and
then there's of course a dose that's a
little bit overkill
and i took the zinc and the selenium and
the carnitine and the taurine and
making sure i was in the caloric surplus
at every little vector that you can
optimize to
recover testosterone production and get
the most amount of testosterone
um while while you're recovered i tried
besides
um red red light therapy
red light was supposed to help yeah
right and then i heard another couple
right another couple of guys that rub uh
vitamin d3 under testicles
yeah listen there's there's a military
where is that
right right so whatever works works
right what about the talk about ali why
don't you touch that because there was a
guest that um
joe rogan had on recently that said that
they had studied
yeah yeah i um i've
heard a lot of anecdotal evidence that
it didn't work
okay and i've seen anecdotal evidence
that the ashford under root extract
worked
okay so i decided to go with that one
and so and i figured you know what it's
gonna take some time anyway
um so yeah i can always put it in later
right and if i recall i think you got
your levels back up to basically like
around the 16 level yes 600 which is
pretty incredible because i mean one of
the things that
that that typically happens when you
like get on trt
or like you know performance enhanced
drugs or a bodybuilder doses
your own production shuts down because
your body just says oh we've got plenty
of this stuff in our blood so we don't
need to make our own
and then after a while supposedly you
know the theory is is that your
testicles get lazy and they just don't
really restart
um but i mean you were on it for quite a
while and you managed to restart them
just
fine yeah and what i see it's not
exactly the testicles that get lazy but
it's the
pituitary or the hypothalamus so when
you shut down your
uh testosterone production it's a signal
right the hypothalamus to the pituitary
to the testicles
and then they start producing
testosterone again it's not the
testicles that chu it's
either the hypothalamus or the pituitary
so that's why we do post psychotherapy
with all these fertility drugs to
restart that signal
but if you take a human chorionic
gonadotropin
which signals the testicles to produce
testosterone
which then cascades into fertility you
see that testosterone comes back
normally and if you run it long enough
the testosterone production comes up
quite high and the fertility improves
also which takes about 90 days
that's why i was off so long because i
wanted to see the non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease was already resolved
long time ago i just wanted to see how
high my fertility would come back which
came back perfectly also
you